[Music]
co-hosting the Golden Globes with your
good friend Tina Fey great this is great
this is really excited the Golden Globes
are a very drunken evening yeah they
serve unlike yeah Oscars Emmys they
serve
um things that you kind of sit in chairs
like you know you would a theater but
this is you sit at a table and the
people get to drink so the crowd is
pretty drunk which is always what makes
for a good crowd like like your audience
our crowd our crowds been preparing for
weeks of solid do you do you have you
performed for crowds that are under the
influence before it can get tricky I
once was a judge at the Cannabis Cup in
Amsterdam is that real thank you it's a
real event where people from all over
the world come to try different weed and
say which is the best weirdly upright
citizens brigade the group that I'm in
performed open for Patti Smith and it
was really strange did improv as opening
Patti Smith at a cannabis competition
that's right the entire audience was so
stoned and nobody knew what was going on
and the guy that was running the the
light and sound board we gave him a list
of our cues like turn the lights out
here turn the music on here in about 20
minutes before Sosa go on he just said
um I got some bad news I lost the list
this is the guy running the show yeah
will you close that'll be a lot of fun
yeah you already advice for me you've
hosted many things I posted things I get
to I get real like crazy beforehand like
and I hey I mean preparing and making
sure like will this work how will this
do how will that do and I torture
everyone around me mm-hmm
and trying stuff out on them and they're
like enough already just go do it and
then never host one again it makes me
miserable but then you guys will be
amazing no I mean lower your
expectations please okay you'll barely
survive the evening
yeah to say to someone you'll be amazing
okay how about this
I doubt you'll show up very good you
have two kids I do how old are they
they're four and two two boys now you
used to tell me when they were first
born that you had the habit of swearing
around them and that you were worried
about it as they're getting older
obviously when they're a year old two
years old you don't worry about it
now that they're getting older are you
worried about swearing well you know I
don't I'm not I have a filthy mouth but
I'm I'm an adult but I don't I've gotten
I but I have gotten much better because
now they're at that age where they're
listening to everything and hearing
everything when they're when I'm around
newborns I just I let it rip I just say
whatever are you swearing at them really
hard I swear yeah
[Applause]
shake up my heart you swear out and then
they're like oh no but Archie my oldest
one is wheezed four and he still has a
few sayings that he kind of we don't
correct him on because they're really
cute you know like when your kid says
something kind of cute you just don't
want to change it you hope that they say
it forever you know did they do
and he says grown-ups instead of
grown-ups which is adorable
so he'll be like I need a you know mommy
you're a grown-up and I just like and I
never want to fix it so that when he
gets old and he's in like his first
relationship he's gonna be like I am a
grown-up you have two boys I have a boy
and a girl and there's a big difference
to boys girls are so smart so early so
early so sophisticated the girls and in
Archie's class like they're like we
can't wait for Santa and Christmas time
and it is a wonderful full season and so
much to celebrate and Arne she's like
you don't eat food it comes out of my
butt
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah but those those girls are believing
in fairy tales he's dealing with science
these are facts these gonna be proven